instantly
Cristiano Ronaldo's girlfriend Georgina
Rodriguez breaks down in tears over the
death of their newborn son is
[Music]
in 2021 the couple revealed they were
expecting twins
Cristiano and Georgina were already
parents to Alana Eva and Mateo and the
soccer Star's dad to 12 year old
Cristiano Jr
but fast forward to April 2022 and the
pair experienced tragedy their newborn
daughter Esmeralda's twin brother died
during childbirth
ashes is with me is something that it's
I want to hold for the rest of my life
and passed through in that moment was
probably the most difficult moment that
I had in my life me and my my family
especially in the season 2 trailer for
Netflix's I am Georgina the 29 year old
influencer explains how Cristiano helped
her through the pain
[Music]
thankfully Georgina seems to be in a
brighter place and the new season of her
docu-series will also have happier
moments
queridas
[Music]
yeah and stars like Bella Hadid and
Rosalia make cameos too turns out the
Spanish singers a big fan of the
showerman
[Music]
thank you